today's video is sponsored by surfshark
i'm sage
i'm a senior at small university in san
diego studying international relations
and my dad is with me here today
clyde tabor i lead a faith-based
non-profit aka your dad's religious
a faith-based
non-profit
all right let's see what's going on so
daddy's going to choose a date for the
girl this is going to go well
personality desires interests
substance etc height
maybe okay i'm 5 10. probably probably
carry on what's wrong no you're just mad
cause you're five nine no i'm 5 10
you're six you just sounded upset when
she mentioned high what's wrong it's
just
your dad has better standards than you
girl god damn i don't know
that's it that's just what i'm saying he
was just like no he was a girl
he went personality substance character
ethics morals
that's that's it bro you know whatever
you think of he went personality
substance height and she went yeah
they gave me that line that's all i've
said i'm not even mad i'm just like your
dad has better standards than you [ __ ]
just burn the whole god damn there we go
i am an includer so the idea of
excluding people based on appearance
is not natural
[Music]
can i give you a hug
oh that's my favorite hesitation oh
damn
oh that is a savage that's cold
that's cold oh
i don't care what nobody says
oh that's cool ah
that's cool
oh
that went ooh you're small you're pale
and oh you want you
dad wants to breastfeed him
come here
come get jesus embrace
oh
come back come get jesus warm
oh
good for him oh
that's oh [ __ ] that literally floored me
that oh yeah
that is a savage
that
that's like when your girlfriend's like
do you like me you're like you're a
punctual oh my god
that's a left
oh [ __ ] that might be the coldest
rejection jubilee's ever had
oh and everybody's laughing like they
know like everybody knows bro we're
gonna see you in another video but this
one is not the one for you all right all
right
can i give you a hug
[Music]
she said no to him he said yes yeah
you're too short hey girl you said no
but do the stall so
your standards well you already know all
the guys who got rejected backstage
won't be doing this
yo question did you go
not yet
all right it smells like you were oh no
i didn't that's you that's not me
hey listen you've asked me my father
before and i admit it oh yeah that's not
me so that's not you no okay i can tell
i would have told you i don't know it
smells like a pretty fart hey you don't
know what a priest part sounds like yeah
you small fighters you would you know
yeah you have no i am listen i think i
know what it smells like when someone's
diet has an absence of eggs
[Music]
i think i know i think i don't want your
hormones that's good
all right yes
bring it
bring it in
you were harder he's wiped everybody but
the short people yeah
so you got the same standards yeah
[Music]
everybody needs to be named and known
and seen and loved and is like
gosh kill her
dad is going to be judging you based on
your handshake and introduction
good call that was brilliant
my name is will hey well clyde hello
good to meet you
nice to meet you i'm caleb kay nice to
meet you good to meet you he's gotta go
he's anybody anywhere
something like this there's the elbow
yeah yeah
extended stan hey how you doing bro you
good good you're good
what's this
what the [ __ ] is yo yo you good i used
to watch this [ __ ] cartoon called red
wall and there was a character that goes
and when you did this amigo
i don't know
[Music]
thailand like the country i love that
thank you okay dude
[Music]
please you want to go after the dad i
ain't mad at you give your life or it
was like
please hug me because your daughter
not the one it's a nice hug my name is
melvin you have a beautiful smile sir oh
man
sucking it up bro yeah you can come on
in i'm arthur arthur this video can i
give you a hug
i'm arthur
and he looked like he was sorry that his
name was arthur i'm arthur
[Music]
thank you you can go
i thought arthur was really cute
with his purple shoes and sport accents
accents again bro
i'm telling you accents there's
something about accents i mean it's just
any kind of action this is different and
like here's the thing about accents when
you hear them they make your ears perk
up because you're hearing the language
you're used to yeah the different tones
yeah so of course it just makes
everything new and engaging yeah like
everything you hear sounds foreign now
so
and it depends we're acting hi my name
is samuel
the [ __ ] out of my face samuel
even that some girls will go over there
yeah
bonjour how are you
i'm looking very forward to meeting you
and getting to know you and your friends
my dad
knows my type and i was like oh my dad
will know he'll know and then i was i
was shocked to say the least
nice to meet you again i studied finance
and data analytics at university of
maryland i currently work as a public
sector consultant okay bro you just said
university of maryland just go right so
you're turning are you turning on the
term
oh my god
did he say turf or turf does that sound
like turf
where they put the thing on just to make
sure because they're like are you i'm a
turf
i imagine
it's a trans exclusionary feminist aka
joyce rowling aka a lot of people that
people get branded anyways all this to
say as fellow terps we enjoy the
university of maryland as well let's
keep playing
i know i don't know why that was very
unplanned i don't know that was visceral
so my name is william go to the
university of maryland as well ah
nice one i'm doing uh i'm currently do
not i do
which part of this college park where do
you live
okay interrogation
where were you what episode of the wire
did you love the most
he went in there how do you feel about
omar
avon barksdale marlowe
the [ __ ] with my turf video is brought
to you by surfsharkvpn a vpn is an
application or an extension that you put
on top of your browser in order to
change or to mask your ip address you
know to change the location of your
computer why would you want to do that
well sometimes i want to listen to other
content from other country and they
won't let me in knock knock who's there
canada won't let you in unless you're
from the uk switch the vpn changer and
then boom knock knock who's there
it's actually the uk now
yes come in lord come have some fee i
know you guys don't speak like that but
you know what i mean so you're able to
watch much more content and then boom
the world is open to you just like
aladdin on a carpet i can show you the
world and for the next month you have 83
off and the three but next month's three
if you use abba and preach code a
surfsharkvpn use the link below go ahead
i like to say that i'm
kinda good at golf so if you want to
play golf sometime
and he's like
i hate golf
no he's like i hate that you know that
as an old white man i do enjoy
i hate that this is working so well
because you know the easy guy went all
the
i play golf
i've been looking for a partner so i
suck at golf but i can teach you
tell me about your family um my mom's
from india uh we used to go every year
um she's amazing uh and i look up to her
for a lot of inspiration uh uh uh uh
you're eliminated that that's the thing
is when you speak
even i tend to do that sometimes when
you're speaking public and stuff like
that um and all those little
things that you haven't that you do
whenever you speak that's gonna change
the whole way people see it of course
well if i want a hypothetical just like
yeah if it's my daughter and i want to
entrust her somebody who i think is
trustworthy or can handle and take care
of her i don't want some dude who's
stumbling and bumbling um um um because
i'm like
you don't seem reliable no right it's
like if you go to customer service and
the person serving you going um well
done
what does this computer do
um
well it has like there's some there's
some linguistic crutches that we have
sometimes and whenever we talk
it doesn't look like you're assertive so
it's gonna make you look a certain way
yeah so all you people at home who like
stutter all the time and stuff like that
like tough luck i don't care
okay so why are you on this episode i'm
on this episode because i'm looking for
love and i'm trying to meet a nice dad
and i'm trying to meet a nice dad
i'm just trying to borrow some sugar
what the [ __ ] you trying to do here oh
you know i'm doing this episode because
i'm looking for love and trying to meet
a mom with some big tits whatever
this
how would you even include that which i
think i think i did i'll be honest i'm
here because like i said i just started
my businesses so i feel like i'm trying
to get my face out there as much as
possible so i ain't about your daughter
that ain't about you too i'm all about
the money
fair enough you know i just love i can
talk i like talking all right dude can i
give you a hug of course
good job
can i give you a hug
yes
i guess you don't want to be a new daddy
no i don't want to that it was weird i
would have eliminated you then too that
is super sus oh you know i'm trying to
be a nice girl and find a new dad what
finally found a dad did i
only eliminate one
i have an idea
i have two questions for each guy the
whole group tell me something about your
spiritual
faith life and what's your opinion about
the border crisis between russia and
ukraine ah
come on
it was going so well
see i even would have let the first
comment slide
because you know what
cool because you know faith matters to
some people and maybe it's popular okay
really
what happened
how did we stick ukraine into this [ __ ]
two questions are we ready boom
i go to the gym a lot and after the gym
i like just meditating doing yoga i grew
up hindu but
i grew up hindu but i want to [ __ ] white
women so you know
i grew up in a buddhist household uh but
you know the white women i [ __ ] are kind
of christian so i'm open mind i grew up
muslim in a muslim household and i would
like to finish in a white [ __ ]
as a bar
hey man listen some people didn't choose
the haram life the haram life chose them
yeah for me um my whole family is
christian everybody's christian um i'm
also a christian as well and question
two i'm not a big fan of russia's moves
in ukraine um i think i mean it's mostly
about crimea right and
i just think they should kind of leave
them alone russia's already big enough
for russia i know they're trying to pull
a false flag on ukraine and try to say
like people are attacking russia so they
could you know listen to this shit's
like listening to arctics on ukraine
this is brain dead
attack in vain it's just going to cause
a huge you know problem in europe far as
i remember um russia is invading ukraine
i'm pretty
ignorant on the topic i said it's like
our takes but our ticks were funnier
our takes at least had some laughs and
some jokes
we had us we had some fun they can go
pick up them rifles that's funny
this [ __ ]
uh russia bad
russia bad ukraine good save the grandma
russia bad ukraine good who likes
pierogies
[Laughter]
russia bad ukraine good the ghost of
careful
russia bad save the transgenders please
get on the train choo choo wait what
what am i watching right now i don't
know much about it i don't know enough
to comment until i don't want to i do
not know much about the conflict to make
an informed opinion so i will not answer
that question i also would not like to
talk out of my ass
i don't know i don't know i don't know
hey you know what shout out to all the
guys that they didn't know and they
admitted it yeah i think that's a very
return response yeah that's great but
let's see how the dad takes those
answers sorry
[Music]
you're to the right you can go
you can go right to the right all right
bro you can go right now all right you
can go right all right to the right he
eliminated everybody who talked
oh
hey man this dad is kind of based
i am mad at him yeah what do you know
about russia i don't know so i'm not
gonna say nothing you can stay hey
you know what i i was about to wreck on
it but this is turning out to be one
thing no
like he's actually uh okay does a
daughter even exist anymore no i don't
even remember who is she i feel like
this guy is grooming the next leader
what's her name
[Applause]
[Music]
do
which one you thinking that's gonna get
it yeah
uh the first one or the second one which
one which one this guy it's it's like
the top three or on no this is the right
side okay the top on the left side on
the bottom yeah well
his right side right now
hi how'd you do oh did you like my inner
ocd kinda
i just had so many questions okay
it's hard you know when i think about
life dating i think my biggest thing
about dating is
the kind of guy you date is probably the
kind of guy you could marry i'm not
saying this is a marriage thing okay but
the direction you start in is probably
the direction you keep going so you want
to take the kind of people that
have that potential i think you will
like this person i think you're going to
find him handsome okay
and i think you may have a connection on
the faith spiritual level okay
and
there's a surprise a bonus feature great
that will wait to tell you the third
thing about it oh this is great okay
[Music]
hold up so faith humanity that's
definitely not who she would have picked
but i'm not mad at it if you better not
say the surprise feature he also went to
the time
he's also a term
i bet he is bet i bet that's what it is
[Music]
my name is will well nice to meet you
nice to meet you too okay what's the
surprise
i don't know i'm assuming it's because i
go to university of maryland
she is not excited about that
it's like it's like she was trying not
to go to that university that's not the
reason
that's the reason
but are you from maryland no my dad grew
up in maryland
i've road tripped maryland which worked
i couldn't tell you i was 12. i ate a
lot of crap
okay i'll have to see you next time i'll
be in new york this summer sorry you can
take me there
this is so awkward
let me go i think her dad kind of chose
someone that he would like to hang out
with probably
it sounds like he was really getting
along with everyone i just was hanging
out with some of the guys and i'd love
to get to know them more because they're
all interesting amazing creative and
encountering people and learning their
stories is just part of the richness of
life i love my dad it makes everyone
feel very loved
yeah sure he has my number so it's up to
him but he seems like a really nice guy
it's not happening
i don't know this field right here this
[ __ ] right here
this
oh that's that's the house camper this
is not happy can this yeah to me but i
could be super wrong but ooh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
imagine getting eliminated and having to
play music for the people who want
it's like how it feels like to be a
musician on the titanic when it's
sinking i didn't even think it was
possible
your ship is sinking but you're still
playing how do you get cucked when
you're not even in a relationship
um
that's weird that's super weird let me
shout out to clyde
and i thought this episode was
overwhelmingly positive but that final
note
was awkward but it's not really because
of clyde though
yeah facts i think it was just you know
producing and stuff like that
it was not clyde's idea to be like okay
you you play the flute yeah play a song
and we're just gonna hand together that
that was not classic you know what this
was
emotional damage